This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here's a trick. If you want to design a good flag, a kick-ass flag like Chicago's or DC's. Start by drawing a 1 by 1 and a half inch rectangle on a piece of paper. Your design has to work within that tiny rectangle. Here's one. A 3 by 5 foot flag on a pole 100 feet away looks about the same size as a one by one and a half inch rectangle seen about 15 inches from your eye. So instead of starting with a big canvas or a wide cinnamon display Try drawing your flag on a rectangle as one by one and a half inches
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。这里有个小窍门。如果你想设计一面好旗帜，一面像芝加哥或华盛顿特区那样酷毙了的旗帜，先在纸上画一个1英寸乘1.5英寸的矩形。你的设计必须在这个小矩形内发挥作用。举个例子，一面3英尺乘5英尺的旗帜在100英尺外看起来，和你在15英寸距离外看一个1英寸乘1.5英寸的矩形大小差不多。所以，与其从大画布或宽屏显示器开始，不如试着在1英寸乘1.5英寸的矩形上画你的旗帜。
You'll be surprised at how compelling and simple the design can be when you hold yourself to that limitation. That my friends is Ted Kay. Ted Kay, I live here in Portland, Oregon and I'm involved in the study of flags. When I went to his house in Portland, he flew the San Francisco flag out front in honor of my visit. That's the kind of guy Ted Kayes. I'm involved with the Portland Flag Association. We are a loosely organized group of people interested in flags, and we are the largest subnational flag organization in the country with the largest membership around 25 dues-paying members, the most frequent meeting,
当你把自己限制在这个范围内时，你会惊讶于设计竟能如此引人注目且简洁。我的朋友们，那位是泰德·凯。泰德·凯，我住在俄勒冈州波特兰市，我参与了旗帜研究。当我到他在波特兰的家时，为了向我的到访表示敬意，他在门前升起了旧金山旗帜。泰德·凯就是这样的人。我参与了波特兰旗帜协会。我们是一个对旗帜感兴趣的松散组织，我们是全国最大的次国家级旗帜组织，拥有最大的会员人数，大约有25名缴纳会费的成员，会议最频繁，
schedule, and the greatest amount of publishing. Unlike a lot of his fellow vexalologists, that's a person who studies flags, Ted is especially interested in flag design. Many other vexalologists are more focused on history, protocol, and usage. There's one school of thought that says, we are flag scholars, and every flag is equally appropriate to study. And whether we like the design or not is immaterial, we should be dispassionate scholars. But then there are people in the second group,
日程安排最紧凑，出版物也最多。与许多旗帜学同仁（即研究旗帜的人）不同，泰德对旗帜设计特别感兴趣。许多其他旗帜学家更关注历史、礼仪和用途。有一种学派认为，我们是旗帜学者，每一面旗帜都同样值得研究。无论我们是否喜欢这个设计都无关紧要，我们应该做冷静客观的学者。但还有第二类人，
like Ted and me at this point, actually, who love beautiful flags and go out in the world and lobby for better ones. Those who are in the second camp have identified a name for those people, and that's a vexalinaire, an activist vexalologist. If you listen to this show for a very, very long time, you know that when it comes to designing flags, there are rules, the principles being keep it simple, use meaningful symbolism, use two to three basic colors, no lettering
比如现在的泰德和我，他们热爱美丽的旗帜，并走向世界，游说人们采用更好的设计。那些属于第二阵营的人为自己起了一个名字，叫“旗帜活动家”（vexillinaire），即积极的旗帜学家。如果你长期收听这个节目，你就会知道，在设计旗帜时是有原则的：保持简洁，使用有意义的象征，使用两到三种基本颜色，不要有文字
or seals, and be distinctive. All the best flags tend to stick to these principles, but one rule, the fourth one. No lettering or seals. That rule, for some reason, Americans just can't grasp. We have tons of flags with writing and municipal seals on them. And that's bad. Here's why you shouldn't have a seal on a flag. A seal is designed to be on a piece of paper,
或印章，并且要具有独特性。所有最好的旗帜往往都遵循这些原则，但有一条规则，即第四条：不要有文字或印章。出于某种原因，美国人就是无法理解这条规则。我们有大量的旗帜上面写着字，还有市政印章。这很糟糕。这就是为什么你不应该在旗帜上放印章的原因。印章是设计在纸上使用的，
to be seen close up, to be seen flat, not moving, and on only one side of the paper. A flag is meant to be seen from a distance on a piece of fabric that's moving and might be seen on the front or the back. Seals don't belong on flags. Seals belong on pieces of paper. Damn right. One of the intriguing things about the fact that Ted K and the largest subnational flag
为了近距离观看，为了平铺观看，不会移动，而且只在纸的一面。旗帜是为了从远处观看，在移动的织物上，而且可能从正面或背面看到。印章不属于旗帜。印章属于纸张。说得太对了。关于泰德·凯和最大的次国家级旗帜
organization are both based in Portland is that Portland didn't have an official flag for the first 100 years of its existence. Portland had several flags that had been proposed and not officially adopted, even though people thought they had been adopted. But that was about to change in 1969. A group proposed a flag to the city. The group was the commercial club of Portland. The proposed design consisted of a white field, that's the background color, with a city seal, in gold, in the center, flanked by two red roses on either side, and then the words,
组织都位于波特兰的一个有趣的事实是，波特兰在存在的前100年里没有官方旗帜。波特兰曾有几面被提议但未被正式采纳的旗帜，尽管人们以为它们已经被采纳了。但在1969年，这种情况即将改变。一个团体向市政府提议了一面旗帜。该团体是波特兰商业俱乐部。提议的设计包括一个白色的底色（即背景色），中间有一个金色的城市印章，两侧各有一朵红玫瑰，然后是文字，
world port of the Pacific on top, and in the words, city of roses below. I think I might have to go lie down. And Mayor Terry Schronunk, who was a various student politician, looked at this design and said, I'm not capable of deciding on a flag design for the City of Portland. This is a job for the Portland Arts Commission.
上方写着“太平洋世界港口”，下方写着“玫瑰之城”。我想我得去躺一会儿。而当时的市长特里·施伦克，一位精明的学生政治家，看了这个设计后说：“我没有能力决定波特兰市的旗帜设计。这是波特兰艺术委员会的工作。”
Smart Guy indeed. But this decision set into motion one of the greatest tragedies and redemptions in Vexological history. The Arts Commission selected an esteemed local artist named Doug Lynch to create a brand new design. Who is a prominent graphic designer, they called him a commercial artist at the time. So Doug Lynch created a questionnaire asking both the City Council and the Arts Commission which attribute should be on the flag.
确实是个聪明人。但这个决定引发了旗帜学史上最伟大的悲剧和救赎之一。艺术委员会选择了一位受人尊敬的当地艺术家道格·林奇来创作一个全新的设计。他是一位杰出的平面设计师，当时被称为商业艺术家。于是道格·林奇制作了一份问卷，询问市议会和艺术委员会旗帜上应该有哪些属性。
As you might expect, the members of the city council had a different view of what a flag should look like. From what the arts commission members look like. You don't say it. The city commissioners were, they wanted realism, they wanted the name of the city on the flag, they wanted a rose, they wanted a mountain, they wanted lots of stuff on the flag. The arts commissioner said it should be abstract, it shouldn't have words on it, much more consistent with our modern perception of what good flag design is. So Doug went into the fray and designed a flag that did not have a
正如你所料，市议会成员对旗帜应该是什么样子有着不同的看法，与艺术委员会成员的看法不同。不用说你也知道。市议员们想要写实，他们想要旗帜上有城市名称，想要玫瑰，想要山，想要旗帜上有很多东西。艺术委员们则说它应该是抽象的，不应该有文字，这与我们现代对什么是好旗帜设计的认知更为一致。于是道格投入了这场争论，设计了一面没有
rose on it, did not have the name of the city on it. It was an abstract design. Doug's design was a... I would call it an offset cross. If you go to our website or pull out your phone, you'll see a variation of this flag that Doug Lynch proposed. It's incorporated into the cover tile of this episode. Two lines crossing from top to bottom and left to right in the center,
玫瑰，也没有城市名称的旗帜。这是一个抽象的设计。道格的设计是一个……我会称之为偏移十字。如果你去我们的网站或拿出手机，你会看到道格·林奇提议的这面旗帜的变体。它被整合到了本集节目的封面图中。两条线在中心从上到下、从左到右交叉，
creating a void in the center that is called a hypocycloid, a four-pointed star. The blue lines that crossed represented the confluence of the Columbian-William and Rivers. The white hypocycloid represented the city of Portland at their confluence. And then those stripes who were bordered by yellow stripes, gold stripes, which represented either commerce or grain flowing along the rivers. And everything was on a background of green representing the forests. It's really lovely. City Council said, thank you for your design
在中心形成了一个空隙，被称为“内摆线”，即一颗四角星。交叉的蓝线代表了哥伦比亚河和威拉米特河的汇合处。白色的内摆线代表了位于汇合处的波特兰市。然后那些条纹被黄色的条纹、金色的条纹所包围，代表了沿着河流流动的商业或谷物。一切都在绿色的背景上，代表了森林。真的很美。市议会说，谢谢你的设计，
and changed the upper left hand corner from green to blue and put the city seal on it. And adopted that flag. I know all the graphic designers and the audience are digging half-moons, shapes, scars, and the meat of their palms upon hearing this violation. It's almost more painful that this abomination was so close to being a really good flag, the one that Doug Lynch had originally submitted. It took a few years, the City Council version of the flag
然后把左上角从绿色改成了蓝色，并放上了城市印章。并采纳了那面旗帜。我知道在座的所有平面设计师听到这种违规行为时，都在抓狂、捶胸顿足。更令人痛苦的是，这个怪物竟然如此接近一面真正的好旗帜，也就是道格·林奇最初提交的那一面。过了几年，市议会版本的旗帜
knaded out into circulation in 1973. But being a relatively poor design with that city seal on it, most people can't tell that it's the city seal, even. It's kind of a yellow, gold blob on blue. The flag was never widely flown. So nearly 30 years later, Doug Lynch joined the Portland Flag Association. He was in his late 80s, and I invited him to come to one of our meetings and explain this whole story of how he had designed the flag and how it was adopted and how it was changed at the last minute. And at the end of the presentation, Doug said, if I had to do it over again, I would widen the blue stripes, move the center of the flag over a little,
在1973年投入使用。但由于那是一个糟糕的设计，上面有城市印章，大多数人甚至看不出那是城市印章。它看起来就像蓝色背景上的一团黄色金色斑点。这面旗帜从未被广泛悬挂。大约30年后，道格·林奇加入了波特兰旗帜协会。他当时80多岁了，我邀请他来参加我们的会议，解释他设计这面旗帜的整个故事，它是如何被采纳的，以及它是如何在最后一刻被修改的。在演讲结束时，道格说，如果我能重来一次，我会加宽蓝色的条纹，把旗帜的中心稍微移动一下，
take that upper left hand corner which is blue and change it back to green and he would take that city seal off the flag. I would make all those, that's how I would do the flag, but it's been 30 years, it's too late now. And they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait a minute. We're the largest subnational flag organization in the country. Look, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait a minute. We're the largest subnational flag organization in the country. Look, Doug, it's not too late. Sitting around the table are the person who has written the history of the flag of the city of Portland,
把左上角那个蓝色的部分改回绿色，他会把那个城市印章从旗帜上拿掉。我会把所有这些都改掉，这就是我会做旗帜的方式，但已经过去30年了，现在太晚了。他们说，哇，哇，哇，等等。我们是全国最大的次国家级旗帜组织。看，道格，还不晚。坐在桌子旁的人包括写过波特兰市旗历史的人，
the person who's written the guidebook on flag design, the person who actually manufactures those flags, and you who designed it. We ought to be able to get this changed. And with the help of future Portland Mayor Sam Adams, they presented an ordinance to the City Council to update the flag. My son Mason who had written the history
写过旗帜设计指南的人，实际制造这些旗帜的人，以及设计它的你。我们应该能够促成改变。在未来的波特兰市长萨姆·亚当斯的帮助下，他们向市议会提交了一项更新旗帜的法令。我的儿子梅森写过波特兰市旗的历史，
of the city flags of Portland testified, I testified Mike Hale, who was the owner of Elmer's flag and banner who manufactured it, testified, and Doug Lynch testified. And Doug was a revered figure in design in Portland. And the commission in effect bowed and said, you're the right person to tell us what this design ought to look like. We agree with your design. And the mayor, Mayor Vera Katz at the time. The mayor said, that's great.
他作了证，我也作了证，制造旗帜的埃尔默旗帜与横幅公司的老板迈克·黑尔也作了证，道格·林奇也作了证。道格是波特兰设计界受人尊敬的人物。委员会实际上低头说，你是告诉我们这个设计应该是什么样子的合适人选。我们同意你的设计。市长，当时的市长维拉·卡茨说，太棒了。
Come back next week and we'll adopt it, but bring a real flag. Can you do that? And Mike Hale, owner of the flag company, gulped and said, yes, we can do that. And so the next week, he'd had his seamstresses sew up a new city of Portland flag. We came to the city council hearing.
下周再来，我们会采纳它，但要带一面真正的旗帜来。你能做到吗？旗帜公司的老板迈克·黑尔咽了口唾沫说，是的，我们可以做到。于是下周，他让裁缝缝制了一面新的波特兰市旗。我们来到了市议会听证会。
The council held a boat on the ordinance, five to zero, they adopted the flag, and Mayor Kat said, pointing to the old flag on the flag pole. Take that down and put it in archives. Can you put that new flag up? And so one of our members, John Hood, went over and put the flag on the flag pole in the City Council chambers, being the first one to raise the official city of Portland flag.
议会就该法令进行了投票，以五比零通过了这面旗帜，卡茨市长指着旗杆上的旧旗帜说：“把它取下来，放进档案馆。你能把那面新旗帜升上去吗？”于是我们的一位成员约翰·胡德走过去，把旗帜挂在了市议会大厅的旗杆上，成为第一个升起波特兰市官方旗帜的人。
The correct city of Portland flag. This current flag with all the updates that Doug Lynch wanted is the graphic that's on the front of the podcast. If you haven't done so already, pull it out, have a look. It's handsome, it's a good flag. Best of all, people in Portland actually use it, especially if you go to a soccer game. If you don't see your city flag anywhere in your hometown, maybe it needs a redesign too. But that's just the vexlin' air and me talking. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mangle, Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars.
正确的波特兰市旗。这面带有道格·林奇想要的所有更新的当前旗帜，就是播客封面上那个图形。如果你还没看过，拿出来看看。它很漂亮，是一面好旗帜。最棒的是，波特兰的人们真的在使用它，尤其是如果你去看足球比赛的话。如果你在你的家乡看不到你的城市旗帜，也许它也需要重新设计。但这只是我和“旗帜活动家”在谈论。99%隐形团队成员有萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·曼格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼，还有我罗曼·马斯。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco, home of a pretty good flag. 99% invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio tapio. For PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，这里也是一面相当不错的旗帜的故乡。99%隐形。你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。为PRX制作。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。